when completed in 1935 Hoover Dam was
called the eighth wonder of the world
rising 221 meters it contains six
million tons of concrete enough to bathe
a road from New York to Los Angeles a
gigantic concrete pyramid wedged in a
desolate Canyon straddling the Nevada
Arizona border 56 kilometers from Las
Vegas the reservoir created by Hoover
Dam Lake Mead covers 620 square
kilometres and has a storage capacity of
over 35 trillion liters enough to cover
the entire state of New York in 30
centimeters of water
Hoover's hydroelectric power plant has
17 generators capable of producing 2
million kilowatts of electricity enough
for 1.7 million homes in sum I got Ken
Xuan public works Enterprise I think
it's one of the examples of an
engineering project where a group of
people came together and achieved two
very advanced goal as far as the quality
of thinking through engineering from
beginning to end
now what if Hoover Dam were built today
what changes would engineers make and
what would they do the same with the dam
have the same design
could the reservoir store more water
could the powerplant make more
electricity and what about the
environment above and below the dam they
really didn't have a sense in the 1930s
of ecology and what kind of damage might
be done that
they couldn't even imagine they've only
begun to realize that in later years
there's this bridge here and this Ridge
here that are huge natural abutments we
asked an elite team of engineers
hydrologists biologists and dam
construction experts to consider these
questions and tell us how they would
reinvent Hoover Dam
to be in this complex reinvention one
must first imagine the location before
Hoover Dam was built
[Music]